[Musique]
joël godard bonjour un jour vous êtes
candidate aux élections législatives
vous vous présentez dans le centre sur
la liste de l'union des démocrates
indépendants
première question pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin je me
présente pour aider me mets mes
compatriotes pour aider les martiniquais
parce qu'ils ont traversé beaucoup de
difficultés et il faut quand même leur
apporter un soulagement donc ma jeu j'ai
voulu relever le défi j'ai accepté de me
présenter lui d ima proposé m'a demandé
de me proposer comme candidat j'ai dit
oui on vous parlait de difficulté vous
parlez de quoi précisément ils ont eu
quand même la crise sanitaire les a
beaucoup affecté il ya les sargasses qui
empoisonne tout ceux qui sont pros du
littoral atlantique surtout caraïbes
maintenant de plus en plus et il ya
aussi le chlordécone qui nous
empoisonnent et donc ça ça réduit le
fait qu'ils peuvent faire des cultures
et puis les pêcheurs aussi sont impactés
par ce problème donc ce serait peut-être
les projets prioritaires pour la
martinique elle serait t'il pour vous
110 mg lieu à l'assemblée d'abord le
social parce qu'il faut quand même
donner aux gens un petit peu plus de
moyens de s'en sortir
concernant la vie chère parce que tout a
augmenté et les minima sociaux ne
suffisent pas il est beaucoup mais ne
minima social doit être augmentée pour
aider les gens et lumineux le minimum
vieillesse ou six et bien sûr il faudra
se battre pour que le smic soit aussi
augmenté et en précisément pour la
circonscription dans laquelle vous vous
présentez à savoir le sentent d'après
vous quelles seraient les priorités
citées en deux ou trois alors la culture
un l'aviculture
la pêche et puis le travail
concrètement si vous deviez être élu à
l'assemblée quelles seraient les projets
les projets de loi que vous pourriez
proposait alors changement de
comme je vous ai dit le minima social
on peut pas en faire une priorité il ya
des personnes qui en ont besoin donc il
faudra augmenter tout ce qui est social
en fait demande à voir une augmentation
bien entendu je sais que lorsque l'état
aide il faut qu'il y ait une
compensation donc la compensation serait
bien sûr dans la création d'entreprise
particulièrement dans la
réindustrialisation la
réindustrialisation oui car voyez-vous
d'autre à rajouter aux électeurs mais un
je leur dis que moi je suis une
citoyenne comme eux jusqu'à présent
parce que je suis pas encore élu et que
je comprends je suis à même de
comprendre leurs problèmes et que je
suis prête à les défendre auprès de
l'assemblée de faire remonter tout tous
les gros problèmes qu'ils rencontrent
pour améliorer les choses améliorer leur
vie s'ils me font confiance ben j'y
mettrai tout mon coeur je leur promets
alors vous l'avez souligné vous êtes une
citoyenne qui partait pourtant campagne
pour la première fois oui est ce qui
motive une citoyenne de postuler un
mandat électif ben la souffrance de ces
de ses compatriotes et elle veut que ça
change elle veut que ça change pour eux
elle veut que ça change pour elle aussi
que je fais partie du peuple donc c'est
un grand changement un revirement pour
l'enlever d'ailleurs on voit déjà au
niveau politique qui a dû revirement
donc on n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises d'ailleurs quand vous dites ça
vous parlez de quoi un particulièrement
lorsque vous des revirements revirement
c'est que les parties je pense que les
parties vont évoluer et certains vont
changer aussi il y aura aussi d'autres
partis y aura un revirement politique ça
c'est sûr là ce sont déjà
voilà donc c'est pas une mauvaise chose
hein on a besoin que les choses changent
a besoin que les choses bougent si ça
bouge c'est une bonne chose si ça bouge
dans le bon sens tant mieux pour nos
citoyens que nous sommes là pour aider à
ce changement à cette mutation est
vivement que la martinique puisse avoir
son essor
joël godard merci
merci aussi
[Musique]